"Тампакс такий непомітний - тільки ти знаєш, що це тампон".
Довкола менструальних продуктів стільки таємниць і забобонів.
Стривайте, чоловіки, не вимикайте! Менструація стосується всіх нас - як і захист довкілля.
І оскільки ми майже ніколи не говоримо про засоби гігієни, стається ось таке.
Мільярди прокладок і тампонів щороку потрапляють у довкілля.
Деякі з них майже повністю виготовлені з пластику.
Наше мовчання на руку концернам.
Добра новина: у нас є рішення цієї проблеми - екологічно чисті та дешеві!
Але поки мало хто ними користується.
Можливо, ви навіть і не чули про деякі з них.
Чому про рішення такої масштабної для екології проблеми досі не говорять?
Адже менструальні продукти - це більше, ніж просто жіноче питання.
Якщо ж підняти це питання, то відкривається багато чого про сучасний світ.
Почнемо з менструальної чаші.
Звучить як щось абсолютно нове, але насправді це існує вже понад сто років!
Якщо ви ще не знали, це не ваша вина.
Ми насправді дуже мало знаємо про те, як жінки поводилися зі своїми місячними впродовж історії.
Але ми знаємо, що жодне суспільство ніколи не сприймало це як щось позитивне.
- Пеґі, звісно, я не можу йти плавати. Червона армія нагрянула...
Більшість жінок використовували те, що було доступно на місцевому рівні:
стару тканину, засушені рослини, листя або навіть глину.
Важко уявити, наскільки це мусило бути незручно.
Не кажучи вже про непридатність для повсякденного використання.
У той час, коли була винайдена лампочка, також з’явилися перші прототипи сучасних менструальних чаш.
Близько 200 людей подали патентні заявки на схожі пристрої для збору крові:
від ременів та мішечків до підтяжок... фартухів ... і навіть спеціальних поясів.
З виходом жінок на ринок праці та початком масового виробництва
з’явилися більш практичні винаходи, такі як прокладки, чаші та тампони.
Цього разу з успіхом! Уперше жінки могли працювати або плавати у будь-який день місяця - як і чоловіки.
У фізичному плані це дає свободу.
Шарра Вострал написала дві книги з історії менструації.
Вона каже, що зазвичай тільки багаті мешканці Заходу мали доступ до таких винаходів.
Бідність все ще залишається серйозною проблемою у всьому світі.
Еліти обрали "безпечні" прокладки.
Вони не могли уявити, що їхні дружини чи доньки щось будуть вводити у своє лоно.
Дехто побоювався, що це може призвести до втрати цноти.
У цьому мало що змінилося - гігієнічні прокладки все ще найбільш широко використовуються.
Вони також мають найбільший - негативний - вплив на довкілля. Детальніше про це згодом.
У середині 20-го століття прокладки витіснили з ринку тампони та чаші.
Особливо під час Другої світової війни. Частково це сталося через дефіцит гуми та її раціоналізацію.
Ідея використовувати гуму для менструальних чаш не вважалася економічно доцільною.
Під час Другої світової війни гуму мали використовувати для шин та речей, які потрібні солдатам, а не для жіночого тіла.
Чаша мала один серйозний "недолік". Коли у вас місячні, ви вставляєте її і знову виймаєте через 6-12 годин,
щоб спорожнити, очистити та продезінфікувати.
Одну чашу можна використовувати до 10 років.
Це добре для довкілля, але це також означає, що продажі значно менші.
Перша компанія, яка масово продавала менструальні чаші, доволі швидко збанкрутувала.
Проблема була не в тому, що жінки не хотіли цей продукт.
Коли компанія закрилася, почали надходити листи, в яких писали: "Можна мені 10 чаш? Мені потрібна чаша!".
Тоді як чаші витіснили, прокладки постійно вдосконалювалися: з липучками, крильцями та пластиковими вбираючими шарами замість бавовни.
Лише зі зміною покоління та сексуальною революцією тампони також стали популярними на Заході.
У 1970-их роках близько 70% американських жінок користувалися тампонами.
Відповідно - тампони та гігієнічні прокладки почали заповнювати сміттєві баки та звалища.
На початку 2000-их людство знову повернулося до ідеї чаші - але вже з новою - екологічною концепцією.
На зміну гумі прийшов силікон.
Але виробники гігієнічних прокладок і тампонів не мали наміру здаватися.
Уявлення про менструацію так вихолостили, що стало годі уявити, як можна торкатися, чистити та
повторно використовувати щось, що стикалося з буцімто "страшною" менструальною кров’ю.
Наше тіло багато чого виділяє: будь-то вушна сірка чи соплі з носа. Але ми не судимо про це однаково.
Ви не зазнаєте іміджевих втрат через сірку у вухах.
Але якщо у вас помітять менструацію і ви не обходитиметеся з нею соціально прийнятним чином, то поплатитеся.
Завдяки сорому та рекламі сьогодні щороку викидається незліченна кількість використаних засобів гігієни.
Вони забруднюють хімікатами та мікропластиком повітря, ґрунт та океан.
Цей сором найбільш очевидний у патріархальних культурах Азії, де жінки, які мають менструацію, все ще вважаються "нечистими".
Виробники тампонів усвідомили в середині 1980-их років, що країни з низьким та середнім рівнем доходу є найбільшим ринком збуту.
85% жінок з менструаціями у світі живуть у країнах з низьким та середнім рівнем доходу.
За словами гендерної дослідниці Супрії Гарікіпаті, в Індії близько 80% жінок, які мають менструацію, не мають доступу до засобів гігієни.
Тому цей ринок дуже багатообіцяючий.
Уряд також працює над поліпшенням доступу до засобів гігієни, але пропагує традиційні шкідливі для довкілля гігієнічні прокладки.
Гадаю, намір був добрим. План насправді полягав у тому,
щоб допомогти жінкам з малозабезпечених сімей отримати доступ до гігієнічних менструальних засобів.
Але вони вирішили піти легким шляхом та використовували наявні знання та рекламну техніку виробників гігієнічних прокладок.
Розповсюдження одноразових гігієнічних прокладок -
це як роздача пластикових або паперових одноразових тарілок для щоденного харчування замість звичайної тарілки.
За державні гроші їх розвозять по всій Індії.
А тим часом звалища переповнені пластиком і токсинами з цих продуктів.
Імідж гігієнічних прокладок можна змінити. Важливо дати жінкам вибір. Нехай вони самі вирішують, що їм підходить.
Давайте розглянемо альтернативи, які відрізняються залежно від бюджету, доступності та впливу на довкілля.
Спершу погляньмо на найпоширеніший варіант - гігієнічні прокладки.
Їх найлегше дістати, але найважче позбутися.
Гігієнічні серветки можуть складатися на 90 відсотків з пластику -
від проникної поверхні до додаткових абсорбуючих полімерів усередині, які вбирають кров.
Вони прості у використанні та утилізації.
Але оскільки системи утилізації у всьому світі незадовільні, гігієнічні прокладки здебільшого потрапляють у природу.
У середньому за 40 років менструації жінки витрачають до 5000 доларів на гігієнічні прокладки.
Далі тампон. Ті, що з аплікаторами, мають додатковий шар переважно одноразового пластику.
Але не тільки аплікатор, але і сам тампон складається з декількох шарів пластику.
Від шару, що тримає його разом, до вбираючої серцевини.
І нитка теж часто виготовляється з пластику.
Загалом вони містять менше пластику, ніж гігієнічні прокладки.
Тампони також можуть бути нешкідливими для довкілля, якщо вони зроблені тільки з бавовни.
Так краще. Але переробляти або утилізувати їх все одно складно.
Протягом життя жінка витрачає на тампони близько 2000 доларів.
Останнім часом спеціальна багаторазова білизна для менструації набуває дедалі більшої популярності на Заході.
Складається з двох шарів: зовнішнього стійкого шару з пластику або натуральних волокон, що запобігає підтіканню.
І другого - вбираючого шару з тканини, що контактує зі шкірою.
Таку білизну можна носити до 2 років. Але прання вимагає часу і зусиль.
Чаша багаторазового використання нині на порозі камбеку. Звісно, до неї слід звикнути.
До того ж, з міркувань гігієни необхідно мати доступ до проточної води.
Але популярність такого менструального засобу нині зростає.
За продукти багаторазового використання спершу слід заплатити дорожче,
що є великою проблемою для людей з низькими доходами. Але вони окупають себе за час використання.
Одна чаша може замінити приблизно 20 одноразових прокладок або тампонів за цикл.
Це близько 250 на рік. Протягом усього менструального життя 4 чаші можуть замінити до 10 000 одноразових продуктів.
Просто позбутися стигматизації менструації, зробити її нормальною темою для розмови - це вже прорив.
Я думаю, це може бути по-своєму радикально.
Ми отримуємо інформацію від виробників. Це призвело до того, що міфи довкола місячних посилилися.
А з ними і забруднення довкілля. Нам потрібно менше стигми, менше сорому, більше обізнаності та кращого доступу до альтернатив.
Чша - лише одна з екологічних ідей. Існує значно більше. Не забудьте їх перевірити!